منورات مالابار الدوليه لعام 2022 انطلقت
منذ نحو اسبوع وشاركت فيها اليابان
والولايات المتحده واستراليا والهند
المناورات انطلقت من ميناء يوكوستا في
محافظه كندا واليابانيه الذي هو اساسا
قاعده عسكريه بحريه امريكيه
من مرحله المشاهده الى المشاركه في هذه
المناورات ويسعدنا ان يجري مع المناورات
بحريه وجويه لتعزيز التكتيكات العسكريه
بين صفوف القوات المشاركه
حسب وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه شاركت مع
مجموعها 14 بارجه من الدول الاربع في بحر
كنتو الجنوبي بما في ذلك حامله الطائرات
التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه التابعه
للبحريه الامريكيه يو اس اس رونالدو
وهبوطه طائرات الهليكوبتر على متن السفن
وعروض طائرات حربيه مضاده للغواصات
غزوه اوكرانيا وتهديد وكوريا الشماليه
وازدياد نفوذ الصين عوامل جعلت اليابان
تخشى محاولات تغيير الوضع الراهن بالقوه
لذلك فهي تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه لا سيما
في غضون السنوات الخمس المقبله
تشعر حكومه البلدان المشاركه في هذه
المناورات بالقلق اذا الصين وكوريا
الشماليه
تقول البلدان المشاركه في هذه المناورات
ان هدفها هو الحفاظ على منطقه المحيطين
الهنديين الهادئ منطقه حره ومفتوحه
والتصدي لاي نوع من النفوذ احادي الجانب
لتغيير الوضع الراهني بالقوه وتبدي
البلدان المشاركه في مناوره مالابار
استعدادا للتحالف والعمل معا لتحقيق الامن
الجامعي لحدود كل منها مهمه سموره الجزيره
من ميناء يوكوستا كندا